let's bring in robert redfield former
cdc director and expert on both covidon
public health doc you heard what sarah
sachin had to say there she believes
that the union in chicago is posturing
holding her children and others hostage
what does the science say about what the
teachers union is doing
well john thanks for having me well
first it's so important to keep our
schools open to face-to-face learning
you know and i've said this before we
can do it in a safe and responsible way
the reality is the school is probably
the safest place for these students to
be so
i don't think their decision really is
grounded in science i don't think it's
grounded in
our knowledge of what the situation is
i just hope that many of them start to
reflect
on the vocation that they have and and
really commit themselves to get back
into teaching because that's what we
need last spring dr redfield shortly
after you left the cdc the agency came
out with a study that showed significant
actually profound mental health impacts
uh caused upon students by remote
learning what the teachers union is
proposing to do here would seem to only
exacerbate a situation that we're just
beginning to recover from
yeah john there's no question that the
public health interest
of k-12 students is not served by remote
learning whether it's the nutritional
support that millions of children get or
the mental health service support that
over seven million kids get whether it's
the ability to detect
uh child abuse whether it's just the
um
mental health depression loneliness
uh suicide drug abuse
not to mention that a number of these
children fall off their learning curve
you know you've seen specifically as we
heard in the group right before
kids with special needs some of these
kids fall off that learning curve and
some of the kids are never going to get
back on the learning curve so this is
really not in the interest of children
the public health interest is to keep
these kids in face-to-face learning it
can be done safe and responsibly it's
actually safer than having them at home
in the community doc i wanted to see if
you could decipher the latest guidance
from the centers for disease control on
quarantine isolation and testing
the cdc says you can now
get out of isolation and quarantine
after five days you don't have to test
but if you want a test and you've got
access to a test you can go ahead and do
it it's very confusing for a lot of
people here's what jinsaki said at the
press briefing a short time ago when
asked if the cdc was actually following
science here listen
the cdc is absolutely led by data and
science
and you know again if they hadn't
changed their recommendations over the
course of time schools would probably be
closed across the country a deflection
there from gensake as to the actual
question let me ask you this about their
guidance regarding the time of isolation
and whether or not to test can you make
head or tails of what they're saying
well john i agree with you it's highly
confusing
first i'm in favor of reducing the
isolation time period quarantine time
period where it makes sense so going to
five days based on how these viruses
replicate in the body a couple days
before symptoms a couple days after but
i'm totally not in agreement with their
decision not to do a test i think we
really need to embrace a test at day
five and if you're negative you can test
and return if you're positive then
you're going to need to get a test again
i personally wouldn't wait till day 10
because the whole purpose was to get
people back into the workforce so if you
it day five and you're negative uh you
go back to work if you're positive you
stay in isolation if you test at day
seven and you're you're now negative you
go back to work so the idea that they
didn't embrace knowledge of infection as
fundamental to whether you return to
work or
in this issue of schools where we call
it test and stay it's critical that we
use this testing as our guide and
embrace knowledge of infection very
serious shortcoming and i think it's
really confused the american public
great to get your read on this dr robert
redfield former director of the cdc
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else